new video here for eight new for eight
news now has obtained in connection to a
teenager who says she had been held
captive in the north Las Vegas home our
eight news now investigators first
reported that the teen claimed she was
trapped in the home in unlivable
conditions and how Child Protective
Services may have had the chance to
rescue the girl sooner thank you so much
for joining us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce
and I'm Christian Gossett as well we
spoke to a neighbor who witnessed this
moment and after asking questions we now
have a response from the county
this woman who wants to only be
identified as Maria claims something
strange has been happening at her
neighbor's home on Spirit Sun court near
North 5th Street and Craig for more than
six years the biggest concern she says
happened last week when the teenager
next door escaped the home from the
Second Story window the girl got out and
jumped over our backyard seeking water
when we saw her she said she had climbed
down using sheets but she was heading
back up this neighbor tells us the
teenager was drinking water from her
hose before she crawled over the
concrete wall when The Neighbor asked if
she needed help she pointed to her
ladder in the yard which would help her
climb back up to the bedroom window
neighbors called North Las Vegas Police
and according to reports when officers
arrived the teenager said she was locked
in the room where she was currently in
and the room did not have a knob but
only had a deadbolt lock which required
a key for both sides which she did not
have the girl told police she had
escaped to get some water from her
neighbor's spigot she said she only
received food when her mother returns
home from work
police say three adults are being
accused of locking the teen in a bedroom
for more than a year with little food
and just a bucket to relieve herself
Addie Gonzalez Who police identified as
a teenager's Mother Maria person who
police identified as a teenager's
grandmother and Daniel omescua each
faced charges of child abuse and false
imprisonment police said a 13-year-old
sibling also lived in the home but was
unharmed
overall it's very heartbreaking because
I told her to call the police and she
refused saying no one would believe her
or 8 news now investigators discovered
the Department of Child Protective
Services received eight previous reports
of allegations of abuse and neglect
citing a lack of cooperation or evidence
officers took the teenager from the home
and I remember her telling them she was
very thirsty as she was being placed
inside the patrol unit
well the three adults are no longer in
jail Clark County did release a
statement about this case which reads
this is a tragic event and while Clark
County cannot comment on the specifics
because of confidentiality and ongoing
investigations we are ensuring that all
the support that is needed is available
and will be provided